Society be to make money or have strong
family units that create good children
and good people I would argue number two
so if this is the goal the bad part but
just imagine imagine that's that should
be the goal man woman together right but
what happened was for whatever reason
there's a group of people I don't know
an institution someone out there that
thought the best option would be not
together a broken family unit now this
sounds horrible right man woman apart
okay so what did they do they thought to
themselves we can convince women of that
so what are we gonna do first we're
going to give women the right to vote
and make them think that we're equal so
men and women are equal